[Music]
hello and welcome to the
debate called artists crusade from the
writings of swifts and dickens to guys
third of may and picasso's guernica
art and literature have often been
interwoven with politics
and today in the wake of the global
pandemic and black lives matter protests
many argue that art has no alternative
and that a failure to recognize the
political character of art
makes the work worthless so should we
see all creative work as playing a vital
part in forming the culture of our time
and so
inherently political or is this to
undermine the very nature of art itself
which should be focused on creating
works of aesthetic value
and offering new ways of making sense of
the world
well we have a stellar panel to debate
this eileen miles who's a poet author a
political activist
who's won innumerable awards as well as
actually running to become president of
the us which is about as political
as you can get francis morris
uh has worked for tate been a curator
for tate since 1988
and was appointed tate modern's first
female director
in 2016 and suranesh kapoor is a turner
prize-winning artist and world-renowned
sculptor
who's produced some of the most
recognizable pieces of political art
in the last 20 years so i'm going to ask
each of them to do a three-minute pitch
before we start the debate on the
question do all artists have a duty
to make a political statement francis
morris you start
why not okay um so i want to start with
uh vasely kandinsky's painting cossacks
and states collection
some of you will be familiar with it the
concepts of its title are scary legible
just identifiable as black dots in a
thrilling
swirl of pigment painted on the eve of
the russian revolution
it stands for the power of ascetics over
politics
subject matter sublimated by pure color
form
liberated from content the retreat of
the artist from the real world
and that has been the story of modern
art for much of the last century
in fact this debate is a very modern one
the notion of the ascetic as a category
that underpinned the fine arts
did not exist until the 18th century it
emerged as the old commissioning culture
gave way
church and state replaced by the private
collector
craft relegated in status in deference
to fine art and the great academies
established with their hierarchies of
genre their exclusions of women and
workers
an era of transcendent value liberating
the artist
and indeed the viewer from the
responsibilities that shaped cultural
traditions
of centuries art history shaped and
instructed the story
of western art as a master narrative of
exploration and conquest
a story of pioneers just as compelling
as the narrative of colonial exploration
and conquest
that provided the backdrop to it art
history accounted
for the shape and content of our museums
and galleries
nurtured the markets and in turn forged
an enduring association
between money and artistic value but in
truth
no artist lives outside their time
however high the ivory tower
however white the cube they and their
work are intrinsically political
because both artists and work are
embedded in the ideological and cultural
context of their time
so the real question is not about
representation per se
although metaphor and analogy are
powerful tools of communication
tanya baguera the cuban activist artist
in a recent performance work entitled
tatlin's whisper
replaced kandinsky's cossacks with real
mounted police
who kettled the audience in the museum
space i often contrast brigara's work
with kandinsky's
what is at stake in her view is not so
much
representing what is political but
acting politically
and that is about the artist's duty to
think about the consequences of their
practice
that duty manifests itself in many
different forms
as british artist robin roberta smith
has observed
to draw a lemon or a landscape can be as
deeply subversive
at a time when our education secretary
declares that choosing
arts in school can hold children back
it can also mean joining forces and
protests as culture declares is doing
but the battlegrounds are now shifting
and in this new age of the anthropocene
engulfed as we are by the pandemic
confronting climate and ecological
disaster
and communities divided by class and
race we are challenged to confront the
urgency
of a different kind of representation
the question of who gets to be an artist
who's doing the talking who isn't
talking on behalf of whom
and who is listening that's the pitch
thank you francis anish kapoor do
artists have a duty
to make a political statement well
i'm going to have a go um picasso
once said painting is war
it is not decoration for your living
room
i want to put this alongside bobby sands
the ira bobby sands that is the ira
prisoner who died on hunger strike
he said war is won not by the pain
inflicted but by the pain that can be
suffered
i say it is in the mythological
translation of pain that there is art
by taking their own lives rothko
pollock van gaal give us mythological
reflection
on the anguish and pain they endured and
their pain therefore
residual in their work we can't separate
one from the other
artists let's not forget make
mythological
propositions they do not make aesthetic
objects
susan sontag reflects that the most
effective art
as memorial to the vietnam war
are the photographs of eddie adams
capturing that moment before
death in his picture of the execution of
the vietcong prisoner
the imminent moment is drawn out to be
poetic
timeless heartbreaking
sadly the most terrifying witness to the
holocaust
is the newsreel footage of the camps and
not
i'm afraid the art made to reflect it
w h is one of that rare breed of artist
who could write
in the midst of calamity his age of
anxiety
is still poignant
these lines and his great work and
you'll forgive me for trying to read
them
um tell us much about where we are today
but the new barbarian is no uncouth
desert dweller he does not emerge from
fur forests factories breed him
corporate companies college towns
mothered his mind and many journals
backed his beliefs in this age of
coronavirus of black lives matter
and of ecological disaster we are
confronted by much that is confusing
culturally black lives matter reminds us
that we have to wreak the rethink the
basis
of our cosmopolitanism not enough for
our cultural institutions
forgive me francis to fiddle around
at the edges of the abomination they
called world
art while it is central to their beliefs
that all great art is white and male
time to end cultural equivalence
we have to learn again how to look how
to read a thing for what it is
and not for where it came from or what
gender made it
ecologically we need to rethink the
christianizing of our environment this
post enlightenment moment
has to mean that we learn to accept the
raw
the wild the unchristian first in
ourselves
and then as a consequence in the natural
world
this is a reversal of at least a
thousand years
of the taming of the savage uncovered
oh dear we are led by a bunch of etonian
upper class excuse me that i'm with
women
but cuts what on earth can we expect
from them
they they can only be counted on to
continue to fortify the capitalist model
that put them where they are art then
according to me can't be led by the need
to say
anything what i know as a man or as an
artist is of little consequence
it is my intuition that must lead me
my mission has been and continues to
be the de-schooling of myself
in i'm afraid the absolute certainty
that this frees my spirit as i
forge onward beauty
then like political rights are not a
promise to come
somewhere sometime in the future beauty
is here now my job is to recognize
and act okay
so eileen anish says it's all about
visceral beauty but do you think that
artists have a duty to make a political
statement
um i think it's so interesting that on
issues that were
[ __ ] and um made it be uncomfortable for
women where i think it's sorry i'm sorry
it's more uncomfortable for me as an
american because i think the word is
used so radically different
in in each of our countries i've seen
entire tv shows
where people could not get over that
difference
um so i think art and politics are
always contextual
there's no separating it um you know i
think
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below
or visit iai dot tv for more debates and
talks from the world's leading thinkers
on today's biggest ideas